like how do you know
when you said there's some people good
at articulating what perfect looks like
what a good design is like if you're
sitting in a
in a room and uh you have a set of ideas
about like how to design uh
a better processor how do you know this
is
this is something special here this is a
good idea let's try this
so have you ever brainstormed idea with
a couple people that were really smart
and you kind of go into it and you you
don't quite understand it
and you're working on it and then you
start you know
talking about it putting it on the
whiteboard
maybe it takes days or weeks and then
your brain starts to kind of synchronize
it's really weird and like you start to
see what each other is thinking
and it starts to work like you can see
work like my talent in computer design
is i can
i can see how computers work in my head
like really well
and i know other people can do that too
and when you're working with people that
can do that
like it is kind of a an amazing
experience
and then and every once in a while you
get to that place and then you find the
flaw and it which is kind of funny
because you
you can you can fool yourself in but the
two of you kind of drifted
along yeah into the direction i was
useless yeah that happens too
like you have to because you know
well the nice thing about computer
design is always reduction in practice
like
you come up with your good ideas and i
know some architects who really love
ideas
and then they work on them and they put
it on the shelf and go work on the next
idea and put it on shelf they never
reduce it to practice
so they find out what's good and bad
because most
every time i've done something really
new by the time it's done
like the good parts are good but i know
all the flaws like
you